I'm admittedly biased but I think this  course is on the most interesting topics  there are it's about origin of kindness  as when we help perfect strangers it's  about cruelty as Anna savage things we  sometimes do to each other it's about  the moral views we hold including views  we hope that differ from other people  such as our views on gay marriage or  abortion or torture for the most part  will be drawing upon research and theory  from psychology but we'll also pull from  other disciplines such as philosophy and  evolutionary biology in behavioral  economics because all of these have a  lot to say about the nature of our  morality we'll focus on how it is that  other people can disagree so much over  the moral views that are so precious to  us and because of that i think this  course has the potential to help us  understand not only how other people  work and how the world works but also  give us some insight into ourselves